Welcome back everyone the Sony the Marvel people
just revealed that Chiwetel Ejiofor is going to
be one of the main characters in venom 3. most of
you know him as Baron mordo in the MCU the Marvel
movies he also played sorcerer's Supreme Mordo in
the a38 universe so they know there's all kinds of
questions about a version of Baron mordo suddenly
showing up in venom 3 because we just saw Michael
Keaton's MCU vulture show up in the Morbius movie
Inside that Universe there's also a lot of talk
about them working up to a version of knull inside
those Sony's Spider-Man spin-off movies like the
Venom movies so I'll explain that too because
there's some cool deleted scenes from Venom
Let There Be Carnage where they do reference the
knull character if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos and
speaking of big Multiverse crossovers Spider-Man
across the spider-verse is going to be the next
big Marvel movie and big Spider-Man related movie
dropping really soon of course I'll do all kinds
of videos for that too I know there's also lots
of questions about that like all the Multiverse
crossover Tom Holland Spider-Man Toby Maguire
Andrew Garfield Tom Hardy's Venom crossing over
with spider-verse stuff I'll explain with some
of the larger plans are the next couple of
years because everything is sort of building
up to Avengers 5 King Dynasty in Avengers 6 Secret
Wars even the Spider-Man stuff that Sony is doing
separately from the MCU is sort of spinning
up for a crossover in secret Wars but if you
didn't see the news Chiwetel Ejiofor is joining
Venom 3 they didn't reveal exactly which version
of the character he's going to be playing there
are a lot of theories about him being a Barren
morto variant I'll explain what happened to both
versions of mordo that we've seen so far in the
Marvel movies they've only been two that we've
seen that we know of there are also a lot of
theories that he's playing another huge comic book
character like a lot of people want him to play
the knull character because I think he does have
the gravitas to play a character like knull but
it does seem pretty early for that there's some
cool deleted scenes in venom Let There Be Carnage
where they actually reference the gods of the
Symbiotes which is basically the knull character
keep them pay for what they did to us all
humans are pestilence oh God why look to
God when you have him right here the father
of all but technically isn't Eddie Brock's
monster your father a new breed wait
I will eat your face sorry sorry to
those who speak of humanity we say only our
Offspring survive we can create a new race
part human part symbiote that will
rule the world the young Holy Trinity
that was part of a much longer deleted scene
during Venom lithography Carnage it sounds like
a lot of that movie wound up on The Cutting Room
floor and there were just a lot of ideas that they
threw at the wall and they weren't quite ready to
do a version of Noah yet so they just took that
out the whole idea with the no character is that
he's like the Thanos of the Venom characters the
symbios themselves so that would be something
they work up to over like 10 years worth of
movies you wouldn't go right to that I've done a
bunch of videos about him in the past because he
has a deep connection with the celestials and
what's happening with the eternals movie and
they just started to get into that during the MCU
Marvel movies he's a Celestial god-level being who
existed in the void of nothingness before the Big
Bang which is also what erish and the judge was
saying during the eternals movie claiming that
he's the first Celestial and he existed before
the birth of the MCU Universe now the celestial is
a little bit different because they're a different
group of celestials for every single Universe
there's some characters in the Marvel Multiverse
that are multiversal beings so there's only one
of them for the entire Multiverse and that's
knull there's one knull for the entire Multiverse
characters like that are like the one above all
Galactus for example super powerful character
there's a different Galactus in every single
universe as well too just like there are different
Infinity Stones for every single universe so it's
a very rare thing if you're a multiversal being
it means you are crazy powerful the whole idea
with Noel is his grand plan is to destroy the
Multiverse and return everything to the chaos that
existed before the Big Bang and they're kind of
doing that heading up into Avengers 5 King Dynasty
and Secret Wars because they're Loosely adapting
the plots of both the versions of Secret Wars like
the 1980s version combined with the more modern
version that's what all the incursions are about
that they started teasing during Doctor Strange
Multiverse of Madness and they'll continue dealing
within Doctor Strange 3. different universes
colliding with each other destroying one or
both of them so it is possible that Sony could do
a version of knull at some point tied to all these
Secret Wars storylines that they're doing the next
couple of years and the other funny connection to
Deadpool over in the Marvel movies Deadpool 3
is a movie where they're actually going to be
causing a ton of incursions the way that Kevin
feige talks about it he calls it a Tipping Point
like you see all the dominoes of the Multiverse
universes toppling destroying each other you have
to imagine during that movie even though it's a
Deadpool and Wolverine movie like Wolverine is
the main character you mostly blame Deadpool for
stuff like this he winds up saving a version of
Wolverine but in the process winds up destroying
or almost destroying the entire Multiverse which
sounds exactly like something the Deadpool would
do you can let me know in the comments if you want
Chiwetel Ejiofor to play a variant of Baron mordo
or if you want him to play character like no like
somebody totally different inside Venom 3. the
only other cast that they've announced so far is
Juno Temple and a long time ago Michelle Williams
said that her and weighing character would be in
all the sequels so she'll be back and they have
it absolutely confirmed Stephen Graham yet but
he played Detective Mulligan during Venable to be
Carnage he turns into the toxic character in the
comics and he got powers at the end of animota B
Carnage so they were really teasing something big
with that character they have to pay off in venom
3 or they could always decide to Swerve on that
because if you remember the morbius trailer there
were all those Spider-Man easter eggs all these
scenes that went up on The Cutting Room floor
so Sony is not above just completely removing
a bunch of ideas that they teased in previous
trailers and movies the last time we saw Baron
Mordo was the sorcerer's Supreme version of Baron
mordo who was part of the Illuminati in the 838
Universe Doctor Strange Multiverse of Madness and
at the end of the movie Scarlet Witch controls
the body of Wanda from that reality kills most
the Illuminati except for Baron mordo she left
him alive he's probably pretty salty about her
killing the rest of his friends R.I.P Professor
X Reed Richards Captain Carter black Bolton Maria
Rambo Captain Marvel the other interesting thing
about the aftermath that there have been reports
that they're going to pay off the missing Iron
Man with a Robert Downey Jr cameo in some Future
movie or he might wind up playing a version of
that character in one of the big crossovers that
are coming up I don't know if that'll come to pass
but they did explain that it was a version of
Iron Man in the 838 universe that created those
Ultron Bots I talked about this during my doctor
strange Multiverse abandoned videos Tom Cruise
addressed the rumors he said that because he was
booked filming Mission Impossible 7 at the time
that the talks for him to guest star as a version
of Iron Man didn't make it that far along so the
reports are that Marvel just decided to Swerve on
that character completely and save him for some
future Robert Downey Jr Cameo scene we'll see if
that winds up coming to pass because part of the
plot of Avengers 5 King Dynasty and Secret Wars
is supposedly going to borrow from The Avengers
forever storyline during that storyline a version
of Kang winds up using an evil version of The
Avengers from an alternate universe against the
normal 6-1-6 Avengers so it is possible we see a
version of Robert Downey Jr fighting for an evil
version of The Avengers that'd actually be pretty
cool the other cool deleted scene with Baron mordo
that did make into the theatrical cut of Doctor
Strange Multiverse about us was the original
6-1-6 Baron mordo from the end of the first
Doctor Strange movie if you thought it was weird
that you didn't see him during that movie it's
because he was in the movie for a little while
I just wound up being a deleted scene I think
the idea is that when they were going a little
more hardcore with the opening like the rated R
version of Doctor Strange Multiverse of Madness
it was more of a genuine horror film during the
beginning of that movie in one of the opening
scenes Scarlet Witch was going to come and kill
the original 616 Baron mordo it would have been
their way of introducing hers the villain of the
movie like oh she's evil now during the theatrical
version they buried the lead having the shimogorth
looking creature come for America's Chavez even
though for copyright reasons they couldn't call
the character schumachworth because technically
the rights for that character rest with the Conan
comics and Marvel doesn't own the Conan IP they
just published the Conan comics for a little while
even though Sam Raimi is awesome the original
director of Doctor Strange to Scott Derrickson
wanted to do a rated R film like a genuine horror
film in the MCU Kevin feige would not let him do
it though the Saving Grace on rated R Marvel
movies is that they've confirmed Deadpool 3 in
the Craven movie will be rated R the Kraven movie
will be a hardcore r film I just did a breakdown
of the trailer that they released for that at
Cinemacon so I'll link that at the end of this
the whole idea with all the spider verse crossover
like we're talking about Spider-Man across the
spider-verse in secret Wars is that they're
trying to build up all these characters for a
secret Wars Cameo eventually in live action they
already referenced Tom Holland's MCU Spider-Man
and the events of Spider-Man no way home during
the spider-verse trailer it sounds like they're
slowly working those spider-verse characters up
to move into a live-action universe and set them
up for Secret Wars Cameo eventually they tried to
have Tom Holland Cameo during the first Spider-Man
into the spider-verse movie but he was too busy
filming on all the Marvel movies at the time to
actually do that and because during Spider-Man no
way home Andrew Garfield specifically references
coming back to do this quote-unquote again I
think that was a reference to Avenger Secret
Wars there is the Madame Web movie The Madame web
is a Multiverse character it's also possible that
Sony uses that in their Spider-Man spin-off movies
to sort of set up a larger crossover for Avengers
Secret Wars it may be even something with knull
eventually too separately from all the secret War
stuff Sony wants their own big crossover that's
more of a Sinister Six kind of thing let me know
in the comments which Spider-Man do you want
to be part of that Sinister Six crossover movie
because eventually they do have to pay off
all those Spider-Man references that they're
making personally I would love for that to be the
Andrew Garfield version of Spider-Man I've talked
about that in all my Venom my morbius videos just
because there were so many Easter eggs for what
they're doing now in the morbius the Venom movies
during Andrew Garfield's Amazing Spider-Man 2 so
it just makes sense they even made a bunch of
Amazing Spider-Man 3 jokes during Spider-Man no
way home when they were promoting that movie like
The Amazing Peter number 3 I'll do more Venom 3
videos when we learn more about what's going on
with that movie more about the characters and
more about the crossover and more spider-verse
videos as we get more trailers everyone click
here for my brand new Kraven the hunter trailer
video in Easter Eggs and click here for my new
Deadpool 3 teaser video thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe and maximum effort!